citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to watch dread neither of us have seen
we did just watch Judge Dredd we had a
very particular time with if you didn't
watch that go check that out it's
available right now I had a good time
with it he had a good time with it but
both acknowledged boy oh boy was that
not the best of movies we've heard this
one is however so please leave a like on
this video so we know that you liked the
good dread because we hear it's great
now I'm excited to watch more action
movies let us know in the comments what
action movie you think we should watch
next because we're very excited to do so
and speaking of wonderful sexy rejects
the patrons get this whole shebang they
can watch not just our resting faces but
our resting dread faces
so head on over to patreon and become a
super sexy reject and you can watch this
front to back beginning to end without
gaps in its entirety without further Ado
it's time to Grimace it's time to see
what justice prevails it's time to judge
dredge
[Music]
oh America is an irradiated Wasteland
within Eliza City cool that's
the cursed Earth inside the walls the
cursed City so searching from Boston to
Washington DC
an unbroken concrete landscape 800
million people living in the ruin of the
old world how it feels like like Dread
the emotion immediate red yeah and I
love that there's no flavor to the
architecture it's just blue yeah I know
it's grounded Mega City one
awesome
convulsing choking breaking under its
own weight I think I better love this
movie koi very happy so far
I'm fighting for order in the chaos
what cool production do men and women of
the Hall of Justice Stark but
interesting yeah make it realistic more
real grounded juries executioners
judges
it's like they use real City shots and
then they impose VFX over it and they
added like cloned buildings to make it
look neutral
and vehicles sector 13.
it's got goosebumps suspects are under
the influence of Narcotics
that bike is awesome
[Music]
are they doing illegal substances those
are drugs that are fake YouTube it is
not real
that is visually stunning yeah this
looks really appealing
I said we got a judge there too think of
everything
I am
oh
I like how that van looks smelly the
entire atmosphere feels very palpable
yeah the production design is gorgeous
on this
oh my God I love it I love how real
situation that was oh just perps just
wiped out of medicine I'm taking him
down a reason for the escalation unlike
Stallone
[Music]
yes what a shot
charge their asses judge
judge oh they're judged
he judged the hell out of them
control paramedics to my GPS multiple
wounded and bodies for recycling it's
like a Dawn of the Dead Vibe about this
right oh that's a good call
release the hostage unharmed and I
guarantee you a sense of life in an ISO
cube without parole oh he's negotiating
what is this this isn't my dread
you want a very good negotiator judge
you got no elaborate beverages your life
dumbass
negotiations over
here I'll kill a
yeah I heard your hot shot
wow
holy shot oh
this is microwave that guy's face this
feels like when someone makes a great
fan film it feels like a student film
but like but one of those like great
ones you catch on YouTube they're like
this should be a feature they did it
yeah Cassandra Anderson 21 born in a
block 100 meters from the radiation
boundary wall at age seven she lost both
parents to residual Fallout cancer
as is usual with orphan she was given a
judge aptitude test at age nine I care
about her now how many people are
observing you
two
what can you tell me about the person
I'm with what just happened she has
powers well another judge oh she's a
psychic I can feel anger
control empath psychic the radiation I
want you to take her out give her one
day in the field supervised see if she
makes a grade chuck her in the deep end
it's all a deep end
[Music]
District 9 also had that why doesn't
everyone make movies like this
is that Lena Heady yeah yeah I heard she
was in this oh
that is awesome that is really gorgeous
what is this
fake drug that slows down everything and
sparkles it we got trouble they were
selling Stern Hammer product On My Level
I run them off with a beaten a couple of
weeks ago oh I love this guy yeah me too
he looks like Luke Cage right now
chain yellow black jacket
okay
are they gonna show that I don't know if
I want to see that hit him with a little
slow-mo first
is that what it's called they're gonna
make him feel it for longer oh that's so
evil
like wait the ramifications
oh that's so evil
holy crap oh so he lives the fall longer
oh are they gonna do that how does that
even work
because your body is actually I don't
understand
your perception of time is altered
unlike many but if you fall your body
would hit the ground before you know
what I mean but your perception would be
slower on the journey so like time is
relative
[Applause]
there's so many and they skinned them
and then tossed 12 serious crimes
reported every minute 17 000 per day we
can respond to around six percent which
six percent your show rookie you tell me
peach trees Multiple homicide Droid to
control we'll take peach trees okay this
one actually feels like an anti-hero
yeah versus Stallone she's just like
unhinged
just murderous yeah judgment vagrancy
three weeks ISO tubes but prioritize
murders correct
but prioritize murders
ew
damn
makeup in this movie huh
it's a Coburn from a slow-mo inhaler
only just hit the grid but it's making
big waves I love the title of that slow
Mouse
guess it felt like a long way down
wild that is haunting
drugging someone so they suffer more is
so messed up it's gonna be like okay
yeah people said it was I remember like
many years ago people say it was like
die hard uh because going up oh is it
one place I mean they're here now
they're going up the building yeah sorry
for Rooney
I heard that too it's all right
immediately
I think it's a punishment killing
someone's trying to send a message don't
with the mama Clan the mama client we
have her on record for most days
Madeline Magica that's her AKA Mama ah
clever I'll trade markers and violence
Jesus
I love how gory this is so intense the
victims are registered to apartments on
level 39 so purpose will be in the
vicinity find out where the clan operate
on this level and hit it hard what a
great Exposition tool you just learned
about this Empire they're like we're
taking them down right now guitars
wondering when you'd remember you left
your helmet behind sir a helmet can
interfere with my psychic abilities like
Magneto think a bullet might interfere
with some more
[Laughter]
you ready yes sir you don't look ready
just adrenaline sir I love the weird
pairing of these two yeah they're great
cool
gnarly how did they shoot this is it on
like a phantom that's then slowed and
lit different yeah
oh I love it
dude icky what beautiful violence such
beautiful violence oh look at the mirror
shot
[Music]
requesting meat wagon to peachtree's
level 39 we have four bodies for
recycling and eight live for the iso
cubes let's get them cuffed move it's
cool that's a recycle The Dread is the
constant and then she's gonna be the one
on the character Arc yeah yeah and the
exposition that comes from it
why
don't even give you time to look away
saved me a lot of paperwork if you just
confess right now
download Gleason
I think you're right yeah yeah this
would be super early Domino Gleason
touch it
no no no no no
uh Caleb there's a problem on level 39.
or is it the guy from Cabin in the Woods
Frank Kranz yeah I don't know I think
it's Dominic redhead racist if they're
taking him in he'll talk what are we
gonna do we're gonna take back King's
Landing whoa
that was sick cybernetic enhancements
hacker man hacking ghosts
two I see why people want to sequel to
this
control room is secure yeah I'm trying
to find things to criticize to make sure
people know we're not promoting jack
on this channel oh well this movie
that didn't get a sequel that didn't do
well
I just want to check you were notified
about the Defcon systems test today if
you check the uh I've got nothing we are
good to go right now I've got my
supervisor breathing down my neck
wow she is intimidating yeah how
did all emergency services are notified
to ignore
you can run
like she didn't even have to do like wow
she's so cold so he's thinking about
making a move for your gun yeah
he just changed his mind yep
[Laughter]
really good humor here
that doesn't sound good
flood smear warrant ya get up you're
headed for the cubes
doors
oh
you know if that homeless guy wasn't
there they could have walked out those
doors by now yep
[Music]
damn the DP for this movie just did such
a great job yeah I wonder what else they
did this is so good
you're patched in
I am the Lord
that's his cameo focusingly
somewhere in this block are two judges I
want them dead
until I get what I want the block is
locked down I'll Clan every level not
the judges Town everyone else clear the
corridors and stay the out of our way
until the shooting stops I love how
there's like a soft coldness in her
voice Mama it's like a posturing
sympathetic patriarchy of like malice
yeah that's so good you're on assessment
rookie call it man I want warm Target's
obstructed line of sight gas grenades
respirators I love the respect she still
shows yeah it's like a short assessment
I'd be like we're about to talk to hell
with this assessment that's how bad
every day is
foreign
you got five
thanks for the heads up
oh
excellent excellent a flash grenade in
this world what are you waiting for
rookie his crime is attempted murder of
a judge the sentence is death yes
isn't his head like oof
it's so hard to see someone's thoughts
than end them yeah and I like how you
didn't cut to what his thoughts were you
just felt watched it with the acting
yeah
oh that's great great choice
you don't want to snitch on them they'll
come shooting up that place that's so
clever secured the woman somewhere she
can't raise any alarms uh we can't she
has a baby asleep in the Next Room
they're a father it's out there looking
for us oh my God I'm not raising any
alarms if the men out there don't know
where you are you won't be killing them
there's a service elevator near here
the sun Genesis broken but it's so it's
script is so good it's been going to pay
your Riders
it works as long as you're hitting a
button above level 75. I just want you
off my level away from my family it's so
realistic makes so much sense ah what an
efficient way to make it like even more
personal and then make the choices make
sense yeah God and they just up the
stakes for every civilian they made
every death more impactful it's so good
you meet one family so you've met them
all
so genius it was like such an efficient
way oh and it was the guy she killed
yeah
oh man
full lockdown they're going nowhere
I tried to do this clean but they
wouldn't let me so now we do it messy
foreign
Lobby whole position behind the Elevator
Shaft to be a good place to defend if I
don't come back and you get cornered you
might not want to get taken alive that
is good that's true yeah I heard about
your kind kind of hard to believe it's
real like what am I thinking about right
now
oh my God
I'm picturing a violent sexual liaison
between the two of us in a pointless
attempt to shock me
but I wasn't trying to shock you if I
was trying to shock you out of it
thinking about this
what I'm thinking about now huh
[Music]
God I love how ugly this world is but
it's so gorgeous
real fire
God damn
yeah a lot of people kill judge her just
standing next to these turrets
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
get back
this is a little excessive I like that
you actually feel the stakes even though
we know they have to make it yeah
[Music]
cool clever that gun has good voice
isolation recognition and all that
gunfire stuff yeah
oh I love the word with people we met is
great
but they're at the top of the building
this skatepark is here to catch up there
on the ground floor oh no no 39th or
whatever yeah yeah okay that was clever
they established how high up this is
calms it back on control do you copy
oh Gods man if they come for us we've
got nowhere to go
good advice thanks lady
also effective
I love how ominous of a figure is
your gang locks down the whole block
Massacre is an entire quadrant of men
and women and children just to take out
two judges
she's afraid of what you might say and
that's got me curious damn do you have
sharp teeth yes yeah what did they do to
make those look like that yeah
you
are so good at acting with his mouth it
is one of the actors instruments coming
yes yes but like they've taken away all
of his other instruments it's very
impressive
welcome to the inside of your head do
what I like sure
[Music]
oh man I figured that would shut you up
hey
I can play mind games too
all right
oh that flush moment the way they
capture that footage looks like a snuff
film that was unpleasant peach trees is
the manufacturing base for all the
slo-mo in mega City one mom was
controlling the production and
distribution across the whole city
interesting stand right here right by
this flag judgment open the blast door
right now we've had a software
malfunction and I've lost control of the
system you better get control fast thank
you
so terrifying it's like she knows
getting him to be afraid gets him to
think faster
keep moving and attempt to avoid further
detection or find a place to defend what
about we attack is that an option
well she's guilty we're judges
[Laughter]
I've ever seen a movie where like a
building is a city it's so cool
man the way they play with like the
different lenses and cameras so neat
freeze
why
I'll shoot you with the safety on it
isn't
how do you want it kids
body bags or chief cubes
very different Stallone Stallone would
have murdered them right in the face
sucks they really need that guy alive
yeah why wouldn't they kill him now they
know everything because they still need
a confession and yeah for the law
you're so
you can't like infiltrate his mind right
now bring Xavier yeah right let's break
his mind maybe because she's under
duress and it takes concentration I'm
assuming yeah
Carl Irvin must have stood in the mirror
for so long going how can I communicate
emotions
now then what am I gonna do with you
you're going to do nothing
you let yourself get taken like the dumb
you are but um
you dead man if you let him talk I can
trace which terminal he's using
you'll know exactly where he is
inhabitants of peach trees
do you think he'll say I am the law I
hope at the end
[Laughter]
of the same rules
[Music]
I am the law yeah
[Laughter]
it was like second place it might happen
struck me in carrying out my duty will
be treated as an accessory to our crimes
and as for you Mama
judgment time
[Music]
he's only 10 levels below a South quad
balcony terminal 5.
they got him yep he's dead obviously
it's not him
incendiary
yes
God the way they take advantage of the
reflection in his visor
such good work all the over the
shoulders are amazing too usually it
does not work they've done like five of
them they're all great
we're gonna stop this guy
call 9-1-1
I really love the way Lena Heady plays
the role like it really could have been
a cliche performance yeah but she brings
some like messed up depth dude it's like
dude you can feel a past with her she's
she's terrified yeah you're standing
outside clock's on the lockdown not
function with their defense system
open up now
oh well they're all dead yep judge Dead
Two judges trigger Turf War judges die
in Pursuit Of Duty and the purpose who
killed the judges laid out here sounds
right excuse me
oh she owns these cops this killing's
all about One gang the mama Clan I'd say
at least one of your two judges are
still alive
you're prepared to justify to them sure
oh dread's gonna have to kill these
judges judge the judges oh who judges
the judges who influences the influence
Trey who watches the Watchman one
million credits
you have a problem with the church you
know who he is no
I do
one million that's Rico
third act introduced I was cloned for
others
very good twist
where's the other one the rookie we got
her here alive
make her dead if you're gonna be a judge
we gotta talk like this I have good lip
control that's part of the
qualifications to becoming a judge It's
the final test that's what Olivia
thoroughly didn't pass
he still is a nice voice a lot of the
women with helmets don't talk for a
reason those three points are voice
based
thank you
oh my God he runs low on bullets
Stakes
see like a lot of yellow lighting I
think it's meant to symbolize it I I
have noticed a bit of it it also it
makes me think of like a smell like
yellow is always like piss rot or piss
like acrid yeah like a basement yes it's
no purple and green I'll tell you that
much
[Music]
foreign
I wonder if this was shot on like HD
film if there's such a thing
extra print quality film I
it's digital this thing is incredible
everything it looks like film and at
times you could tell the HD camera yeah
it feels like like a red dragon or
something like finchery though identify
yourself
dread sector 13. responding to a 10-24
he doesn't know what's
up too long negative three-man Squad
closing on my Vector right now two of us
called in the 1024.
wondering why you didn't ask about the
other one
let's move it
I was smart
choke on it red
ouch oh
oh
oh my God he oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
this movie makes me feel sick I hope
Fred cries he refused to stand for
something
you betrayed the law You Were Meant to
judge
now this I always wanted one of these
this is
you got any last words yeah the
Titans Remember the Titans that's funny
I was going to ask you that
let's see it
I rare from the first movie and they
were like we had prior Exposition yeah
[Music]
I've got the girl cold I see her first I
shoot her she sees me first she
hesitates then I shoot her I bet these
judges are stunt performers
they have that energy yeah
Tribe Called Quest
oh my God refill or is that just all
slow mo I think it's on Slumber but the
gold cap so that was bullets yeah
Universal bullets
just what I need in this video what's
the price of a judge these days
million
split four ways
three ways now
doesn't sound like much
to portray the law
betray the city
scumbags
rapid fire
damn it oh Cindy Harry armor piercing I
love this
[Music]
two-way split
[Applause]
few out and just run out of bullets
can a judge grab another judge's gun I
think it's their ID because then they
can it has to be framed somebody else
okay yeah yeah like how Rico framed
exactly because the DNA because he was a
clone
we watched the first one I'm your backup
psychic
with the helmet
okay I don't know it only blocks her
like it's an output okay not like
magnitude
on the piercing
that was a well done reaction moment I
did not expect this
wait Judge Dredd
is he judged red
he don't beg finally gets on the wrong
end of a gun
what he says
is weight buying time I mean wait for
what
wait for me to change my mind
wait for another two or three seconds of
life because you're so weak you
just can't stand to see it end I had to
say was waiting this guy's coming with
his ego
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
becomes a predator
I love like the scuzziness and the sweat
yeah this movie must have flopped hard
to not get a sequel yeah people are
clamoring Forks it's great this is
awesome yeah it's so like tactile it's
so bushy ready yeah
you look ready haha that's a good
callback I like that
this movie's very viscous
it's just wetly
yes
squeal Pig
Mama's in her private choirs but it's
behind ten inches of Steel so you can't
get in there without keypad combination
I I I can give that to you
[Music]
he's a victim get out of here
betting a felon is not just a fail
offense it's a crime he's a victim not a
perp and until my assessment is formally
over I'm still entitled to dispense
Justice and that's what I just did
I love you
[Laughter]
you are the law
by law I heard answers
Mrs dread awesome
great greatest of the shots oh man and
this training you just see like the
co-working because their training is
genius
[Music]
it's just got that icky cyberpunk Vibe
yeah love it man
oh she like magnetized the room I guess
so
you think I didn't know I get busted
someday it goes with the territory this
entire level is rigged with enough High
explosives to take out the top 50
stories oh God
it's a transmitter sink to my heartbeat
my heart stops beating
the building blows
put your gun down if he hits her with
slow milk could he could get her out of
there
yeah
how was how is he gonna
have no idea
what are the next moments yeah you're
right
we're a kilometer above ground
what do you think of the ranges on that
thing gotta get through 100 levels of
concrete how about 200.
let's find out
oh and he threw that guy off the
building in front of her yeah it was
like a warning sign your crimes are
Multiple homicide and the manufacturing
distribution of Narcotics
how do you plead
all right
defense noted
oh my God he's a smashed her through it
that's neat the beginning of the movie
you see her do this yeah but this time
you're gonna see it in her POV yeah
where they save the POV for this and
then you see all the Carnage she caused
yeah
there's something strangely tragic about
all this
oh my God
do I want to watch this I don't know yet
I don't oh
ground POV they made us the Splat I love
Gore and sometimes I'm like I don't know
if I want to look at it it's a lot
[Music]
yeah yeah
so the guy just shot her right there was
no magnets my brain just went like how
did she get shot
I guess that's the case
the depiction of Mama's backstory
reminds me of real life criminals of
heard of like Kingpin women who like
yeah you know turned that into their own
pain and put it back out your
assessment's now over
you did okay
you didn't want to be a judge in the end
so what happened in there
looked like you've been through it
perhaps were uncooperative
so how does she do
she's a pass
[Music]
if she wants it tune in to the movie
that should have gotten made dread too
800 million people living in the ruin of
the old world only one thing fighting
for order in the chaos judges
[Music]
yeah
brilliant
they credited the creators of Judge Judd
first before anybody yeah much like the
first one it loved the comic which I
respect that's incredible
that was brilliant I've never seen that
in a Credit First
Pete Travis who are you I love you Alex
Garland oh wait I I remember hearing the
story behind this is Alex Garland
There's issues that happen with the
directing and Alex Garland pretty much
was the one who actually ended up really
directing this movie one of those cases
where it was like I forget what I
remember hearing that forever ago
um but yeah this was like really Alex
Garland I mean he's one of my favorite
directors workings that makes a lot of
sense yeah a lot of the visuals but that
also makes sense why I never saw a
directed like yeah I've looked at his
filmography 100 times I've never seen
directed my everyone knows that he
pretty much directed this one oh it is
incredible
man I was cool the one of the script was
so good yeah
Alice Garland Jesus that was incredible
I mean I I feel like we pretty much are
commentary alone pretty much uh said
what we felt a lot of what we would say
and the review portion of this it was
just an hour and a half review
um but yeah the
in that respect to Carl Urban for not
taking his mask off the entire time not
a single that was the least uh like Diva
like he didn't at any point need to be
like I'm Karl Urban under here yeah you
wouldn't never if I didn't know it was
Carl Urban I probably would have been
like who is this guy underneath or or if
I'm not plugged into the industry if I'm
just a person that watches movies I
would have been like man a stunt guy
finally got his break yeah I mean even
if I hate concept artist jock that's
what I was talking about last week they
gave him credit awesome hell yeah
I mean even if as someone who is pretty
much plugged in I still would not have
guessed I was Carl I wouldn't have
guessed that was Carl Urban basically
what I'm getting at I mean like I have
no idea who that is underneath the mask
and I love it proven Batman is possible
yeah I know that was awesome that was so
good he had to do a lot with just he
literally just scowled his way through
an hour and a half Matt what could I he
must have looked I wonder if he did what
happened he did if he didn't have the
mask on how silly he might actually was
because he probably had to kind of do it
a little extra was there one other judge
that shot him through the back like
literally did so much big mouth acting
he was doing the like lips out but it
was great because it worked
yeah man I loved it uh this is like one
of my favorite action movies I think
this is one of the I think my favorite
films I think we've covered here yeah on
the channel yeah like that was
Sensational it was wildly impressive it
was very tight it was not it was like
the perfect run time for this story
didn't feel too short didn't feel too
long I cared about everybody and it
didn't feel overdone overcooked the
dialogue was that 80s dialogue I love
but a little bit more you know aged up
to today but the singers were there yeah
nice pulp to it the you calling the I am
the law right what is about to happen
maybe so happens
I was really happy he's coming I'm glad
we watched the first one first
because I would yeah I would not have
enjoyed watching that next
oh my God can you imagine you know what
I mean oh that would have been a
nightmare but we got cool moments like
the gun we got the the background
yeah but we got cool like Throwbacks
with the the lines of dialogue some of
the World building but we also got like
watching it first the robot which we
loved and things that I might not have
enjoyed as much if I'd see this version
been like what are we doing so I'm
really glad we watched the first one
first but this may be one of the best
remakes that's not a remake
continuations it's just it's not quite a
scene like you wouldn't call it Batman
Begins a remake of the Batman that's
true you know one of the best redo
adaptations yeah because it really has
to be a category yeah what is this yeah
because it's not a reboot really I guess
kinda anyway incredible uh Johannesburg
so it did have some District 9 flavor oh
okay that makes a lot of sense yeah so
this like this is everything I love
about action movies with a certain
budget range that I want them to make
more of and I really wish it did better
because I want another one of these
the one thing oh yeah I was trying to
say uh yeah the one thing
that I kind of craved was a tiny bit I
think it would have just been the one
thing to really add an extra element to
it was I never really feared for dread
that normally that is a major hindrance
for me in an experience like this and it
wasn't here I think that would have just
been the next extra bit of propulsion
for me be because like a bit of that
John wickness yeah you know where he's
like he's really struggling you
know like even though you know he's
gonna be fine yeah you know John work's
gonna be fine a big part of the selling
point is like he's just like really
having a push through and then for
something that is even referencing the
plot of Die Hard John McLean oh he's
pushing through pushing through and he
made he had like one moment here where
he was going up against the judges and
he gets shot but you know he heals up
pretty fast after that I thought in that
moment he might actually die oh really I
was like maybe she becomes the dread
like for a moment I was like I wonder if
she's like you are the law like I
thought we'd like this is what culture
root again oh yeah that was like he
hands in the helmet they ruined the
whole thing
it was a brief moment but it was like
three seconds I really was like what's
going on yeah
it's like it's like uh what's it called
Lord of the Rings crawler but looking
handsome yeah uh but yeah I I didn't
once one of the most impressive things
to me is I now see Carl Urban so much as
Butcher and at no point did I think of
that during this well the dude's got a
range man remember him Star Trek oh no
he's incredible bones is so funny but
like I've been watching the boys a lot
like that's been hours of my life and I
haven't watched a lot of curl Urban like
since because he's been playing it so
long I was so afraid I'd hear the gravel
I'd see the grittiness and I'd be like
oh it's butcher with a helmet nope now
and it's pretty cool how he can play
that that action here the the rough
voice yeah delivery Action Hero uh but
still feel like he brought something out
he brought something different to it
yeah it was like a different anti-hero
gritty like it was all the pieces that
could a lesser actor could have made
similar yeah yeah that's kind of how I
felt about all the characters you know
right down to Lena Heady man Lena Heady
especially you know I I love some good
True Crime docs and she reminds me of a
lot of those real life people who had
like abusive ass pass as I established
here and then convert that pain into
power and criminal under really criminal
lifestyle it doesn't go well get revenge
on society I thought she really brought
a realism to this larger than life
scenario they all did a cold
mercilessness that felt like she had
gone through it to get to that point
like there was a weight and a history to
her performance and I love the dynamic
between you know because that is a
typical Dynamic Men In Black has it
experienced senior agent and rookie
agent right right like there's it's a
it's a it's a it's a common trait
Dynamic for sort of movies and I and I
thought that instead of like let's make
one really colorful personality I want a
straight shooter or something they they
managed to keep it just so in tune with
the world and give very specific
portraits to these two characters
without trying to like how do we make
this more fun or Punchy yeah they've
found ways to make it more engaging and
fun and I like the chemistry between
them but it never relied on a cliche
sense of chemistry at any point A lot of
it was done in a very laconic way like
they did so much without having to
explain but you could pick up on it yeah
they trusted the audience a lot and
that's one thing I talk about a lot of
movies I love is when they trust the
audience and I really love that scene
when she
saves the judges because she wants them
off her floor like that that scene with
the the one family we meet saves so much
time and there's so much where it could
just be like if you live here you're bad
and they didn't do that which I love and
it's for a comic book movie
talk about a visual experience that that
relies not just on a visual experience
but visual storytelling
I feel like I I like I I can I like Zack
Snyder films more than you generally uh
like my love for my Affinity for them
yeah a little bit higher a little
stronger yeah yeah
um
but I did feel I didn't when I did have
certain points I mean just just take for
example the use of the of the drug
slow-mo yeah
it's more it's better it's like a lot of
it was like this kind of feels like
those Zack Snyder visuals but that are
just it was fun yeah like yeah because
like why would that happen as often a
lot of the crazy visuals that they would
choose of how to mix it up felt within
the scene and within the storytelling
you know it was like the third shooter
it was like they're Reinventing another
shootout like there kept being moments
where they they had a shootout and then
five minutes let there be another one
but it was a completely different
Dynamic but it didn't feel like a
different movie it also still felt like
the same stunt style and the same action
that someone trained in a way would do
but they shot it so differently that I
was like more different yeah it just
stayed exciting this was exceptional the
locked off shots the povs like the
moment with the flash grenade yeah
um it reinvented a lot of cool action
much the way that like Jason Bourne
showed you could do like a fight
differently or a stunt Chase Card
something differently this did that with
like gunfu without it being gon Fu it
did a lot of new element with shootouts
yeah it sucks you into the I love a good
like ugly dystopian beautifulness to
that yeah and I think this really
manages to capture that like it felt
immersive it was gorgeous a lot of the
time it feels like an observation piece
I felt truly immersed into this it
smelled yeah I kept talking about the
smell it's the one sensory thing where
you're like wow I could I feel like that
I can taste this in some way yeah like
have you ever traveled somewhere that is
in a rough way the thing you noticed I
noticed first is the smell and then that
immediately turns into a lack of touch
and that immediately turns into like a
sense of apprehension like for me the
smell starts it and I felt that watching
this which is of great success to a 2d
experience I'm sitting in a very nice
place and the whole time I was like I
feel sticky like and I love that if it
even the cyberpunk type score that they
had here if it would feel like it it
could be playing in the building yeah
you know yeah like over the the yeah
yeah it didn't just feel like the score
for the movie it felt like this could be
coming from the speakers within the
building and it wasn't distracting when
there was like sensory overload in a bad
Road it's what I mean yeah then more
yeah I think if they did it today they
could probably enhance some of the gun
play
yeah yeah it's I mean it's still it's
still really cool and I love the gore I
love the violence and it was so sweet it
was squeamish I got nauseous twice
sometimes a little cartoony but I think
it would help that allowed for it yeah
it allows for some of those slow-mo
shots and everyone was like so good at
sounds like a dumb note they were just
so good at acting yeah but there was no
like weak link like I love Domino I
loved that the supporting characters got
their little moments but nobody who had
the like no more Dead Cops like there
was no one ruiner of the tone yeah they
managed to invert a lot of tropes with
like a lot of these characters are art
types that you would probably predict
would be in this story like this like
the guy like the hacker for the security
system but I love how the background of
him was a a truly someone who was taken
advantage of like and we've got to love
her more because of that I love that
they gave us a moment of redemption for
Olivia because we you know we're
following this this girl that's in
duress and so empathetic and they give
her the arc that we need someone to have
as an eye line it's such a great
compliment Elementary type of character
to just dread yeah in a movie called
dread yeah for a guy who is so and I and
I love the aptness of that where you do
feel like yeah the character is dread
but the movie is such a dread heavy tone
yeah
um I'm so impressed but it's not like a
slog or slug dread is usually like the
the emotion of it feels like really slow
and very deliberate within five minutes
we were like yeah well this takes its
time the dread is so palpable I love it
um man great sense of atmosphere
throughout but I love the Dynamics and
yeah the hacker guy Lena Heady even the
usage red everyone had a good a great
inverse of it even um even what is that
actor's name he's in Creed and Remember
the Titans
um the dude who was like oh the the Luke
yeah yeah yeah I didn't catch his name
on the credit side of his name he's
fantastic he was so good at I hated him
and I usually love him and he's such a
great actor uh generally and even that
character
is another one that would have just been
a cliche sleazy guy who probably mouths
off the most generic shirt right I'm
like man they even bring a lot of
difference to him I I guess though when
everyone was recommending this movie the
last thing I was expecting was to be
walking away going the writing of this
is so good yeah I was like I'm gonna
have fun it's gonna be an action movie
that's all I thought it was going to be
and like like the one I think we really
enjoyed recently was extraction I had a
great experience but I'd never be like
you know the writing an extreme
not expect that to be the takeaway today
of like this is such a taut and tightly
written Thriller I'm so impressed like
I'm definitely gonna recommend this to
everyone because I wish there was
another one and when you got in day and
age where uh writers are fighting for
something and actors are fighting for
something this shows what you can this
shows you why you got to pay them well
because God damn Alex Garland writing in
the acting is phenomenal in this film
I'd love if more writers got the
reputation that actors get for like the
consistency of their work and Alex
Garland is absolutely one of them like
when I when I hear Alex Garland to go
yes please and when writers can make
things like this I mean he did ex
machina he did what did he do right
after Xbox I know yes Annihilation right
now he's got a show devs
uh devs is a show right now with Nick
Offerman Saturday 24. uh I believe so
um but yeah that's an option here oh
yeah we should add on to the list I
would love that I also haven't seen
Desmond if that's a24
probably not but uh I can say that uh
Annihilation is another great use of
sound uh like the annihilation have you
seen Annihilation yeah the way they
manipulate sound to make you like
physically uncomfortable well Natalie
Portman's going through some of her like
disorientation I got some of that here
well I think this was the first one he
like ever was a part of I imagine that
he directed yeah it sucks so much
because well it's it's kind of akin to
uh Bohemian Rhapsody right there was
actually There's an actual like guy who
like oh this guy's really directed right
back in his movie yeah Brian Singer did
it you know and especially for an Oscar
movie like that what a bummer what a
hard thing to watch happen yeah yeah and
like I actually the only thing that made
this possible to watch it here to react
with you is had I seen directed by Oscar
I would have seen this yeah so like the
one one good thing is because I never
knew it was Alex Garland I didn't catch
it because man that was Sensational that
was Sensational all fronts man that was
great that was fantastic that was a
clean four and a half stars for me like
I really loved that which is a nine to
nine point five for for the 10 scaler
yeah yeah that was so good yeah that was
amazing I'm tired now I can't believe we
don't have a sequel I'm so upset I mean
it must have flopped hard I can't even
imagine because it was so good I also I
just got a seven point on an IMDb and
that's just not I think Judge Dredd
probably had such a negative effect on
it yeah
because it wasn't and Carl Urban wasn't
exactly a I was even now like he's more
of a household name now than before but
yeah the boys might be the only way we
ever get drafted to 2012 Carl Urban
who's like post Lord of the Rings yeah
what else did he not at that point yeah
there's not really ahead he was probably
the biggest name yeah at the time and I
think Olivia thank you probably was
because of Juno it's probably they kept
her helmet off yeah yeah
all right show her yeah because this was
just relying on the IP of dread which
which is 2012 was like um that was the
year of comic book movies oh this is the
year Avengers came out this Avengers
yeah
it's one of those I got whatever the
year the Hellboy reboot came out this is
like that this is that it's got lost in
the shuffle but it's also rated R which
didn't help it exactly yeah I do Wonder
now if I mean the cult fan base around
this specific film is going on it's just
like a Kickstarter raised to a million
dollars Yeah man they should
really try to get this going who knows
who knows who knows maybe we'll we'll we
can speak in the universe by liking and
commenting on this video close it out
all right we are gonna do another action
movie very very soon please comment
below what you want us to watch because
I've been enjoying the hell out of this
journey uh please do like subscribe and
all those fun YouTube Shenanigans and
share this unlike you shared your love
for dread when it was in theaters
because clearly you didn't uh but yeah I
love the hell out of this uh these are
always fun I love watching action movies
Greg especially stuff we didn't see uh
apparently Demolition Man is the Taco
Bell of lore according to the comments
on dread one so if there's anything else
in that vein do let us know and uh we'll
see you guys very soon and we appreciate
the patrons as ever we're getting into
what month is it August yeah getting
into August so we're back with more
stuff very very soon much love
foreign